the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome to our coverage of the
2023 spring chess classic my name is
Julian perlaco and I'm joined by women's
Grandmaster tatva brahamian
and I guess you're going to take us
through the pairings well hello everyone
and welcome yesterday we had a very
exciting round one so let's take a look
at where we are with the standings that
we did have some decisive results so in
group a we had two decisive results as
Daniel Darda defeated
Benjamin Park and yes sir quesada
defeated the young Christopher you and
uh and now let's take a look at
standings in group b in group b we only
had one decisive result with Akshay
Chandra winning his game and everyone
else drawing but even so we had a lot of
fighting games and some of these games
went on even after we're done with our
broadcast so I think we should see
another fighting day today
yeah so the tournament format is uh it's
a 10 player round robin there are two
sections in a group and a b group and
what around Robin means is everybody
will play everybody the time control is
90 minutes for the first sporting moves
then 30 moves F sorry 30 minutes after
move 40 for the rest of the game and a
30 second increment of course throughout
the entire game
look at what we have today and
um
yeah so the uh the schedule there is uh
one one game per day every day there are
no rest days
um they begin at 1pm
and let's take a look at the pairings of
the day and we see the playing call
right now so the players are playing at
the chase hotel and we have in the group
a so the key matchup of the day will be
some Savion versus Daniel Darden So
Daniel was the Victor yesterday and
today he has the black pieces against
the highest rated player of the
tournament
so let's jump into this game right now
and let's take a look at where we are
so as we're taking a look at this game
we are already on move 25 and we have
some kind of an end game a rook end game
with four Rooks on the board where white
is up a pond so some Savion is pricing
in this position so let's see how we got
here
so some with the white pieces facing a
Berlin
so D4
so of course we know that there is this
line the very famous Berlin drop not
gonna publish here right we are not of
course going to see this with the
repetition
okay so instead he goes Bishop C6 and we
have the Berlin end game
Knight C3 Bishop E7 and Bishop F4
um so I'm not I actually have never
played this on game before have you ever
played it would you play against the
Spanish
um so yeah I I have played some Berlin
in my uh in my life
um with both colors with with both
colors I mostly played rookie one
instead of this uh oh okay so you don't
D4 lines end game
um the few times I have done
usually I play D3 I don't go for in this
position I will play T3 to avoid all of
this anti-burling uh but uh yeah in this
position in this line I also have played
rookie one I haven't gone for this so of
course this is played a lot at the top
level so we go for this end game
and Knight C3 Bishop p7 uh usually Rook
D1 is played with Bishop F4 and it's not
the most common move I was actually
looking at this before um before we
started the broadcast
so I mean this is uh this end games are
um
have been pretty heavily
analyzed by the top players we see them
a lot so H5 usually a common move
grabbing stopping this G4 moves in the
future so the Knight stays on F5 Rook D1
yeah it's It's Curious
um that black plays H5
um because
like white sort of gets an ideal setup
with Rook a D1 rookie uh Rook fe1
um I believe uh instead of H5
um
like my first instinct would be to move
the bishop like to E6 because I want to
be able to play King C8 after Rook to D1
so I wonder why he chose the move H5
after Bishop F4
but in some blinds
well I guess before
I have seen this H5 move before I have
seen this King go here I think this um
this is some game that Wesley was also
playing with the when the King was on
the eighth I think against Sunshine
Glenn in the American Cup
so Knight H4 it's kind of funny right
because here you're like oh I can just
cancel and then all my problems have
solved it's true and I did but then your
opponent we'll call The Arbiter
unfortunately
okay so here is actually maybe already a
critical moment and Bishop E6 needs to
be played because
after A6 immediately E6 was a lot so if
Knight D4 then okay C5 is also possible
so the idea of A6 so that Knight D4 can
be met with C5 so there is not Knight B5
so A6 is played but now E6 and as you
mentioned this King in the center can
actually come under Fire so Bishop takes
Knight D4 actually I'm curious if Pawn
takes
ah pontics we just take and now Knight
D4 and this Pawn is just too weak and if
this bishop is just never going to get
out so black cat to take with the I
think this is pretty thematic as a
nightmare Berlin end game it's a knight
D4
um so now white simply wants to take on
C7 actually and King E7 here is not
possible something black would love to
play because
check and this bishop is hanging
so instead he goes Bishop F6
so capture so now white has an option of
which one to capture but since this is a
weak pawn it captures the C7 Pawn as the
spawn will always be loose and hanging
so capturing the pawn immediately is not
possible because
pieces are hanging
instead Bishop F4 G5
yeah G5 is um defines a bit of a
difficult move to play because you are
creating some more weaknesses although I
do understand this move so the problem
is there's no King F7 because the Rook
comes in
and I think this runs into Rook D6 which
is also problematic so I think you
realize that you cannot hang on to the
pawn
so if G5 with Bishop goes to D6 now we
cut the path of the The Rook not the
King goes to F7 so there's no more Rook
D7 checks so that makes sense
and if here then like think we can maybe
even try harassing this bishop but this
move is met immediately with Bishop E5
and the problem is there's just too many
weaknesses
in Black's position because if you take
in the game King the seven was played
but now I'm just picking up a very
healthy pun yeah Black's position looks
pretty unpleasant already
yeah because I have like my centralized
Rooks and this Rooks are not in the game
so King E7 very logical
so exchange and Rook D7 okay so now
black has to make some kind of a
decision because if you play a move like
Rook B8 then your Rook is just going to
stay here for a while I'll just double
so you can never challenge my rook and
after I bring my king or create a loft
for my king I can start thinking about
doubling on the seven rank yeah this is
very unpleasant yeah and you just have
no counter play
and often in Rook end games we know that
it's better to give up a pawn than
suffer so it's better to activate your
Rooks and give up a pawn and look for a
counter play because even down upon Rook
end games are not easy to win whether up
upon they're not easy to win so he gives
up a pawn activates the Rook okay so
this Rook is actually great
so this move defines B2 so now there's
some kind of a dynamic because if you go
after this a pawn then I will take this
B2 Pawn
so Rook d8 double link on the D file
yeah I like Black's decision to go
active in this case like
um say what you will about black being
down upon but all of his pieces are
pretty pretty good even his K9 F6 is
probably better than White's Canon G1
yeah Rook D2 was a really nice move as
you mentioned cutting off the King which
is
um key aspect of Rook end games because
without because they're not that many
pieces left on the board so the kings
are actually important pieces so if you
cut your opponent's king off then it's
like you're playing with an extra piece
so C3 Rook cd8 Rook B6 okay attacking
both the spawns but okay I don't think
oh actually no Rook C6 is a very big
threat because E6 will hang so he has to
defend C6
and A4 is split
so the idea is
if you take then I take and this
exchange actually is very nice for black
because now white has two disconnected
pants enough to remove like Rook C2 like
for example if we push the pass pound
Rook C2 already the spawn cannot be
defended
so the activity is paying off here for
black instead white plays A4
and this is quite a nice move because we
can push this Pawn to A5 and after we
take on A6 then this power Pawn gets
closer to promotion so it's just better
to have it on A5 if it's going to become
a pass pawn and maybe something like
before A5 and try to win that pawn yeah
I wonder if black should try C5 here
um
in an exchange a pair of Rooks and then
claim that B2 is still weak and we're
still more active than our opponents so
takes takes and
immediately so let's say I go before
like Rook D4 here perhaps
and
yeah actually this looks pretty
Troublesome yeah so we don't want to
allow
uh pass bomb with a rook behind it so
takes takes so before but maybe we can
still try because there's a back rank
weakness but I so there's a problem here
because if you go Rook A2
you don't have time to take because
so maybe there is something else so
after before maybe you shouldn't take
hmm
maybe something like this
and of course this is great even the
pond back
and if Rook B1 now we have to calculate
this
because I think taking this bad takes
takes and threatening so I guess oh oh
yeah yeah
we might be just in time right yeah but
now we're entering some
move by move territory
so if you go after this Pawn I think you
will
okay
now we're on the flag
yeah apparently this is a drug but you
need to be like super sure yeah to enter
some kind of a king and pawn end game
it's very risky because yeah you have to
be 100 sure because rook and pawn and
games there's a lot that can be done but
King and pawn and games you can
calculate them until the end so it
becomes a matter of tempo so this is
very risky maybe we could have played
better with white at some point but okay
yeah I mean C5 I think is a big risky
decision so if he's going to do that he
needs to so it's a matter of considering
if it's better to have four Rooks on the
board or two Rooks on the board so I can
understand C5 because we're trading our
opponents
strong wrong for our
like less active rook and Rook D2 is
coming and now white left is left with
this E1 rook and this bad King but
um
again it the game becomes a little more
concrete instead he played rookie two
of course this is impossible oops
because of mate so this route will go
probably to F1
because if the road goes somewhere then
Rook D2
something like this cannot be a lot
because everything hangs so The Rook
will have to go to F1
and maybe here actually Brook did two is
a consideration
because if you take take
um I'm not sure you can hang on to every
Pawn
for example if I go here
wait why did I go there I wanted to go
here
here and here
barely hanging on Rook A3 probably right
um
yeah so the problem is if I took the C
Pawn then the rule goes behind again and
then this part starts going so I think
maybe we should just hold this position
and
not let Wyatt get out
there
it's a little kind of awkward to make
Blues with white yeah
also giving up to pawns is very scary
right so after rookie two Rook F1 I
think this is the game so let me promote
yeah and definitely Sam is pressing here
for sure
but something like Rook C2 maybe and
just kind of wait around
and not make any committal decisions not
before it's not an option and just kind
of wait around and see how white can
make progress because exchange of ponds
on the queen side is
um not I don't think something that
black wants to avoid because then
when the puns get separated it's easier
to Target them and this Rook is very
inactive on F1 very passive so this I
think good compensation for black
okay
so this was our kit matchup of the day
so what do you think closer to a draw or
a white person for a long time
probably why it's going to press for for
a little bit
okay so the time situation is 13 moves
uh 13 minutes versus 30 and we're on
move 27 so still quite a bit of moves to
make until we reach move 40. and the
meantime let's take a look at the
pairings for Group B so in group b we
only had one decisive result yesterday
after Chandra winning that really nice
game with that Queen D1 he was in the
studio
showing that game to us and explaining
his preparation so that was a really
nice Victory and today he has the black
pieces against Luca Buddhism levitch a
Mizu student and let's go to that game
and take a look to see what is happening
there
so right now we have this position
and this position looks
uh so let's count the pawns one two
three four five six it's the first thing
we need to know this actually looks
quite Pleasant for white I think
Central ponds this Knight is out of the
game control of the e-file so so far I
think white has a bit of an edge this
looks like a queen's Indian of of sorts
where did this come from so let's see
where it come from
six Knight F3 so it comes from BOGO
Indian and C5 so take Stakes
say three
should be three okay so this is where
we've got the spawn formation
so everything looks very normal so far
yeah I've played a similar line with
black but it's I start with B6 and go
Bishop B4 after G3
um and then when they go Bishop D2 I
play the move C5 so very similar
structure simple B6 here then G3 Bishop
B4 and if Knight D2 again Bishop A6 but
if Bishop D2 I go C5
I actually beat Alice Lee here which I
was pretty happy about yeah so something
I haven't managed to do yet uh so did
you oh yes okay so some kind of a mix of
the strut of um structures yeah I used
to play Queens
Queens Indian but um it's a bit
depressing for black sometimes and then
I started playing catalog but I started
playing this line and I remember one
place
Knight C3 and then I started playing
this and I think I've lost so many games
in this variation yeah I also like this
line for black no I've lost a lot of
games here with black then you get this
broken structure
and then your pawns just start to fall
at some point if you're not active
enough
true it's a very sharp line yeah I think
I just don't have a good feel for the
position yet but okay so
we're playing this line so E3 so of
course G3 is another way to develop and
he plays with E3 just a matter of
preference where white wants to put
their Bishop
36 Castle
Knight A6 yeah so then oops
so the Knight is quite happy to go here
so white is just keeping the tension so
at some point white can push E4 and get
this nice Center
it's actually there was a game in this
line wow yeah I think white needs to be
like pretty careful about playing E4
because if you play E4 at the wrong time
and black just gets to play E5 and even
like sometimes you can even like
sacrifice a pawn like this I don't know
if you can do this here but this like
this would be pretty good for black if
you can get the C5 Square
even with the special price because at
some point this bishop can come back and
this bishop also not impressive
also like you want to give up
yeah like something something like this
I I've always found to be like Pleasant
to play with black even if you give up a
little bit of material
yeah this is very awkward for white is
actually not clear how to defend this
bishop because if you go back
immediately you lose the pawn
so already starting to look a bit loose
for white there
so E4 is a communal move because we can
see Square so instead Knight G5
987 oh that's a funny way to exchange
nights
and the bishop comes back okay so
exchanging a lot of pieces
I think he found this bishop to be quite
annoying so he decides to get rid of it
yeah this bishop H7 thing I see a lot of
good players do this because like I
guess the king's a little bit worse on
h8 than it is on G8 so they just want to
make like a slight Improvement before
they played the move Bishop before
um I see this a lot in these Queens uh
Indian and queen scaven type positions
you know this is a nice trick I think
when I was younger I always thought this
is so clever that you check and then you
come back three four well here it was a
capture but in general this is kind of a
thing
so F4 so grabbing some space here rookie
eight
rookie one sort of this logical and
finally five
okay
so now there's some clarification in the
center I think uh maybe black dot is
going to be very passive probably if
maybe afraid of taking the four maybe
this Rook can start going to the other
side of the board so if I was played uh
but this is quite communal like Pawn
structure changes are very committal
yeah I think what having it like played
F4 is some achievement I don't know if
you agree but I I never like like these
types of positions where white has
already played the move Pawn to F4
because it stops the main idea sort of
of playing E5 as easily
yeah and I think white play it's like
block makes some kind of
just want to see how annoying it is
because if I get my Pawn to F6 this
looks actually very dangerous
black will have to take I think
but this also looks quite unpleasant
oh because now you don't have
um
E5 so I can just go E4
so this Rook moves and something like
this is possible
and bring the queen
maybe I can start thinking of an attack
one day and this Knight is very
alienated here
yeah the whole point of the Knight on A6
is to eventually put it on C5 and it's
it doesn't seem like it's getting there
anytime soon yeah this phone is not
voluntarily going to move
so F5
oh no okay one E5 rather takes takes
takes takes and Knight F3 all of this
very logical
yeah this looks quite Pleasant for white
again a lot of exchanges but now white
has a past Pawn so it's three versus two
on the king side so it's going to be
more difficult to make a pass Pawn
tonight is going to E5 and if I compare
this Knights of course the Knight on F3
that's headed T5 is much better so
that's why F6 was played because 95
would have been a very difficult move to
face and now Queen to G6 but here my
natural instinct would be Knight to H4
to put the Knight on G6 or at least
maybe Queen G6 Knight F5
I understand with that light Square
Bishop maybe this is not as scary
because okay if I had a bishop on me one
this would be terrible so 96 King G8
um maybe I'm not really achieving much
but okay I can put a knight on F5 I
think this is quite nice but it started
with Queen G6 I don't think this is um
I think this looks also very normal
ph1
just a housekeeping move I guess maybe
he wants to play um Knight H4 but
obviously right now if you play Knight
H4 then Queen D4 will come with check
which is not good
yeah King H1 like a prophylactic move
putting the Knight away
but now takes and we'll get fate I would
expect Knight C7 here with the idea to
play or
so one of the reasons the Knight is on
A6 is so there's a few things we have to
worry about so I think blocks the
structure of the night lens on F5 can be
very unpleasant and this e-file is
something to worry about and also this
Palm tension here so we have to think
about do we ever want to take or when
why it takes if we want to allow this
take
so I think this is a big consideration
so that's why so rookie one rookie one
was played
wait Rook Cafe it was played okay
uh kind of confused of what's my
analysis once the game so now I'm
thinking if we should play 97 right away
or take take a knight to seven but I
also think this also might be a huge
decision because you're left with this
Pawn I don't know how significant that
it's going to be but I I really want to
be able to the list challenge this
e-file
yeah and I mean maybe B6 isn't isn't so
weak because C4 is also like
kind of undefended and unopened file
okay so if we mean if we try yeah so C4
can also become a targeter Right
yeah I like your knight C7 it feels like
getting mated should be our number one
priority
so he played Rook f8
and now takes
so maybe white does not want to allow
this exchange so maybe Knight C7 is
coming
so Rook f8 what else can we do can we
like no we pushed upon that at night
goes to C5 oh but still Knight D4 even
this I think is Pleasant now it goes to
F5 rookie seven
some kind of a domination here
yeah then I managed to get to C5 but at
the price of all of White's pieces being
really active and good
yeah I like this
this the night before this is the
current position that we have uh so can
I go D5 here maybe
five so what was the difference
so if I go D5 here
so yeah the point of that this is
obvious yeah I like your idea of Knight
D4 Knight F5 it just freezes all all of
the pieces you don't do you need to take
can you go Knight D4 right away
I don't know if that
it's a knight of five
oh I need to move so now you want to go
rookie seven right
can I push
um
so if I play rookie seven ah rookie
seven threads made I thought I am so
clever I can just go here but you're
threatening mate okay
so here I need a move oh maybe queen of
that one uh yeah okay that does yeah
someone is a good resource but maybe
here I can take
all this comes with
with
[Music]
96.
but I think you're surviving are they
surviving here
if I take
okay so if you take
I have made
right
and if you don't take
but
maybe Queen G5 is a move
oh what about okay maybe maybe Queen D2
is super clever ah oh no because I
cannot stand the E file s right to the
way now you win my horse
oh no I lost my horse and then yeah now
I'm getting mated so this is not this
did not go as intended
so what can I do here maybe
okay I wanted to say Rook E7 but Queen
F1 uh maybe it's too much
so here this seven Queen D1
uh here yeah queen queen E8 looks nice
with the idea take check
and hope that we're not getting married
actually I'm not getting married right
because Knight D3 yeah everything is
I just have to cover this
and I'm up a rook
so how did we get here so after we get
Faith
I don't know how I'm just gonna switch
back and forth okay so in this position
we're looking at
D5 immediately yeah maybe the difference
so if takes takes D5 now now we can go
B5
and nothing's starting to hang
yeah and then if you take on
uh if I click on D5 and I'm covering E7
so there's going to be no more rookie
seven
so taking on P4 maybe was less accurate
but okay D5 is not the only move there
must be other moves for white so
like I still think that structure is
really nice here perhaps where you can
try Knight H4
Brave take my intention was to play uh
Knight F5 but I guess you just go back
we saw this right and then no we didn't
see this yeah oh my God sorry
so clean this ah okay so it's a
different version of this yeah because
there's Queen D1 here
can you
am I
um can I can I can I do what so your
next move is Queen F7 right
yeah I guess this is kind of annoying
I'm gonna have some and black is happy
to trade yeah I'm curious why the evil
Bar says that White's better here
because I I don't see anything concrete
and it does now sort of feel like I'm
done upon
um well while these guys are thinking
about this game uh let's take a look at
what they're playing for
so
in group a the uh the top prize is six
thousand dollars second place is four
thousand and third place is three
thousand with the total price fund being
22 000 a huge price fund which is nice
uh for the B group they're playing for a
little bit less money but still quite a
bit first place is four thousand dollars
second place is twenty five hundred and
third is two thousand with the total
price fund being fourteen thousand
dollars they're playing for uh quite a
lot of money
and as you were telling us what they're
playing for I was looking through the
games and this game caught my eye as
black is up two pieces I am
I I haven't looked at the moves yet but
I would assume that white started some
kind of an attack sacrifice too many
pieces
and let's see how we got here so this is
the game between kirgo sarian and
kirkelly Contour
so we have another
a quince Indian or rather Indian defense
so D5
and Knight C3 okay so this is the 364
that I was lamenting about but like play
C6 so we have a sandwich love yeah this
is like the starting position right like
uh they call that the tabia because
um black has like 10 different moves
after Knights Knight F3 Knight C3 you
can play DC4 you can play Bishop E4 you
can play C5 like you think every move
has been played even like age six and A6
have become somewhat popular all right
I've played H6 here and this is a nice
move oh yeah
to do
that I kind of like just kind of avoid
stings and you just ask wide where you
want to put the pieces because they go
eat there at least you're like okay I
don't have to face we should
because with the idea again you're
wasting a move on asking why what to do
if they go we should be two then you're
quite happy because white spans two
moves to take on C4 and now you get in
B5 so it's really justifies
uh this A6 H6 thing which is kind of
funny because this is um against
everything we have learned as young
players yeah you're not supposed to do
in the opening A6 and H6 that they
always told me don't move too many Pawns
in the opening and then every opening
you move all your pawns yeah
I will let you
look up level games
you do yeah H6 is a cool idea so Bishop
G5 so we are entering some sharp lines
this is the antsy Moscow I believe
Andrew five Bishop G3
um
I have tried playing some versions of
this position actually in this line
which I was mentioning before I mean
Bishop D5 is possible here too I have
never played that position with either
color I have no idea what's happening
yeah this positions are by a shop so
okay this is a very long term upon
sacrifice
but it is not this this black as
compromised or King side but even so
it's not so scary for black and
actually I have to
so E5 immediately this is quite the
middle
of course white can start with castles
yeah E5 doesn't feel intuitive because
doesn't Blacklick want to play the move
Knight D5 like this creates a huge
Square on D5 at least to my eyes uh well
the idea is to go like control these
dark squares
so Queen B6 so this is also Theory so A4
so A4 is the Lesser that's common mode
so Knight D4 is more theoretical so A4
is white so um you can guess this is all
preparation
A6 securing the queen side 24 C5
oh and this is the sharp position is
telling us that white is winning I saw
the eval bar go way up but I was like
well the Ed is such a normal move yeah
so computer wants to take with Bishop D5
and keep well okay this is the other
move right it's not like you can give up
a piece of Idi is bad but okay so if
you're a final Place eat it then you
have to find a way to punish them right
because otherwise black would love to
have this kind of a social structure um
the idea Knight F6 I mean I do have the
engine on so I did see the first move
Bishop G4 which is so difficult to find
oh the point is if it takes the bishop
D7 King D7 dc5
wow yeah but I think you have to know
these positions really well just about
this kind of ideas because this is not
very
executive of course once I see the move
I can see the idea but coming up with
the ideas is hard for me
yep yeah I think that's the challenge of
analyzing with the engine because you
look at the engine once you see the
engine moves it's just so logical but
then if someone gives you that position
[Music]
and I think this is also the downside of
when you prepare like very something
very sharp with an engine and then you
play it because then you prepare it
you're like yeah of course and then you
have sometimes you have the position and
you're like oh my God like I'm kidding
made it like or I'm done it feels like
what am I doing why did the engine say M
plus five here I don't know or like you
actually like start analyzing you start
thinking or that your opponent plays a
move that the engine didn't suggest and
you're like but this is so logical like
why is this bad and you just can't
figure it out so I think it's um
like analyzing with the engine can
really influence your thinking because
once you see it it's just so logical and
so easy
yeah and she takes D4 but this position
maybe even taking is possible
yeah this or maybe even something like
this
yeah this is this is what I was thinking
with the idea of playing rookie one next
but I guess it comes out then the king
runs
yeah like Bishop C5 let's say okay one
and I just don't care
is such a nice confirmation
yeah intuitively
but actually I have no good intuition
for these sorts of positions just looks
like you could convince me that either
side was winning yeah Black's Keen is
weak um white just has too much activity
or Black's just up a whole bunch of
Pawns and white has no attack I I would
believe you either way yeah this is very
risky um
still looks a bit scary for black I
think but
um black is up a lot of Pawns here yeah
white better do something
but instead in the game 96 was played
which I think is very logical so takes
takes Queen side Castle uh which looks
really wild but uh black has to go for
this castling on the other side is too
risky because this is without the dice
Square Bishop this king is too weak so
something like H4 I think or even the
idea that we saw with Bishop Bishop D4
F5 here maybe
um but I think H4 here is just um quite
difficult to face yeah maybe bishop G4
F5 is possible because you can play like
Queen C2
2 and if you take
yeah my idea was to go Queen she's six
and and then you take all my pawns right
and then I went to yeah I want to take
on G5 go Queen H5 and then take on D7
eventually oh
um
but maybe we can I like the zigzag idea
Queen H6 Queen G5 Queen H5 Queen G Queen
G4
those were okay so let's try it yeah
yeah this is really nice
okay once this night is gone the bishop
comes in and it's made this king is so
lonely here
but something like rookie one with the
idea of the seven because he is covered
is also extremely strong
yeah so castling kingside is just not
possible so black has to do uh black has
to go for this which is very common in
this position so D takes C5 Queen takes
C5
a b a b and
and F5 so the fact that black got in F5
and because I've seen saw this bishop
before move earlier I think this move
actually
might be necessary just to tie down this
Knight and not to allow F5 so if H5 H5
yeah maybe I can even take
or maybe I should just put a bishop here
H4 Bishop here it was gonna ask about
about H5 because if you take it then
isn't F5 strong for black yeah now you
have a four and G4 yeah so this F5
should not be allowed so we have to put
a physically like stop this Pawn from
moving
and if H4 looks like my Bishop is sharp
but I have Bishop B5 because of this pin
and
it's defend
um
so if King B8
can create what came with them maybe we
can even try Queen D4 I don't know how
you feel about these on games oh Queen
D4 I think tactically oh yeah can we
play Queen D4 last turn
here uh because C5 is
not not protected at the moment okay so
this is hanging
so so okay let's see if I take take
so what is yeah this looks quite I mean
it's just such a domination right so if
I go here yeah Rook A5 like you were
pointing out seems seems pretty good
yeah and then decided if something like
this this other comes in this looks very
yeah this domination this bishop versus
this Knight I mean black wishes they
could just take this T5 con off the
board and just free this bishop with
this D5 Pawn is just it's really
annoying when your own pieces get in the
way of your other pieces especially
pawns because you can do it you can do
anything no this was Queen D4 is a
really nice move
so here instead he went P3 I understand
P3 you're trying to attack
but the problem with B3 don't think you
want to capture this way because yeah it
frees the bishop like who is the bishop
maybe the bishop comes and then
makes this worse but uh Bishop Bishop
before maybe D4 is a move actually
um
yeah definitely you have to calculate
that maybe B4 here I don't know how you
feel about that
okay so take take this is extremely bad
again the same domination this is
probably actually just made right
because Queen B6 is coming yeah so she
takes P3 before she takes but three is
not possible
uh so my queen has to go somewhere so
not too many options let's say here
actually I don't like it here I want to
stay close to my king he was going to
play Bishop F3 on any of those moves
and then like take on take on B7 yeah so
without this bishop my king does look
weak right so I have Queen taste I think
Queen D4 yeah again and if King takes in
Queen F3 I think yeah and if you play
Queen C6 for K7
yeah just before moves very looks very
annoying so I have to go back
I mean I'm kind of nervous about before
because if this doesn't work out and
your opponent has these two pounds
but maybe again back and go for this
idea well down the temple compared to
the lines we just saw
but without this bishop we saw that the
king is extremely weak so it makes a lot
of sense for white to trade those
Bishops
but in the game instead P3 was played
and we see the about just drops
so F5 yeah five I think he missed this
or misjudged how strong it is and just
F4 is coming
so takes takes this bishop is strong so
I think this is probably
nothing to be worried about now because
it's F4
can I take yeah I guess queen of three
we can even play like King B6 yeah the
king just hides here it's just very
brave but but I think it's like too many
pieces are now coming off I've seen this
idea in the bot Finnick where they put
their cane on B6 like voluntarily yeah
and that's just annoying right because
you need your Bishop to be like here
yeah
and this happens in attack sometimes
when you're attacking and you over
commit and sometimes you sacrifice too
much and then you have nothing to play
with anymore and just too many exchanges
happened
so instead he went Queen B1 so okay so
he has to give up a piece so okay five
okay I understand this is looking for a
counter Play Bishop C6 so white is in no
hurry to take the bishop because the
bishop is trapped
so Bishop takes on C4 Queen takes Rook
C1
Queen D5 and this is quite unfortunate
because this is a Tempo move so white
would love to be able to take on B5 here
because this is actually very annoying
but unfortunately it runs into mate but
if it weren't for this Tempo if it
weren't made this queen actually doesn't
really have any
maybe we actually can still take but
okay this is at least Rook A5 we get
some kind of counter play here but
unfortunately Queen D5 comes
um with a tempo
so F3 is played
and now takes Rook takes B5 takes here
and just no entry squares and not enough
pieces for Y2 attack width you need a
minor any kind of Bishop Knight anything
any color Bishop any kind of Knight
anywhere on the board just to do
something the Brooks are just yeah you
put a piece anywhere on the board for
white and Black's probably in trouble
but
yeah just not enough pieces
unfortunately I I was playing so
casually too like okay I'll just support
my king
but no
no it's Roxy Five trying to exchange
it should be someone so Queen H6 was a
threat and cable should be seven defense
Queen A7
Queen goes to C7 Rook B1
but wait this is not the
oh you want a peace bag
but unfortunately at the cost of trading
um so the position that we saw it was
this one right so from here what
happened so he took he brought the rook
in very logical rookie five
Rook C5 and
Bishop B7 apparently it's not ideal here
it's kind of funny right because even up
to Pieces somehow white has some chances
oh now I see this idea of King H2
because Rook C1 otherwise would be
hanging with a check but King on H2
actually defends against this idea which
is so funny because it's prophylactic
move in your
um down to pieces
okay so we're threatening mate
so now we're piling
okay so this is can we can we go back
for a sec was it necessary to uh to give
one of the pieces back with like like
what do you want to do I guess so here
it's already too late so yeah you cannot
move because this is mate
yeah I'm wondering if you could have
done like something earlier
like it's crazy to me that white just
has enough counter play like can you
play Rook C7 here is no no Queen b7's
main yeah that's oh that would have been
unfortunately yeah
that's very nice
um so what happens if I just move my
Bishop
what is the move here is it
so Queen A6 is not a move taking I think
I get away with this
oh it Rooks it too still yeah you still
want a piece back wow so white white
mine had a might have had more counter
play than we first realized
yeah I think the key
no even if your position is really bad
because every chance every move is a
chance for your opponent to make a
mistake if you can just
kind of keep it together
so queen bee sound of course it removes
also a chance for you to make a mistake
but if you can keep it together then
your opponent has tried not to I guess
the upside of being lost is if you make
a mistake you're losing anyway so
but look how much the evil drops this is
crazy to me so if I take take and I pin
you you have to go here
what can I do here okay if I go here
then you have Knight F6
I want to go after this poem
can I just
like perpetually pin you
oh yeah that's that's that's a nice idea
yeah that I don't I don't know how you
even deal with that like how do you
untangle from the pen
because okay if I take one more time my
one more Pond and my chance to stop
trying so okay so first of all the
problem is you have a knight so if I
trade all this Pawn somehow Rook Knight
versus Rook it's just a draw a very easy
draw too it's not like Rook versus
Bishop yeah and we only have very few
puns left on the board so already with
something like King H2 F4 I can trade
another pair of Pawns so even with an
extra piece this like this draw
territory feels close right but it also
doesn't even feel like black can try to
press in that final position like as you
pointed out how does black even untangle
his pieces
so he played King H3 here
um
but you know like rookie one came B7 as
as you pointed out if you just check him
whenever he's on the C file oh I guess
you go King C6 so that you can meet Rook
C1 with with Knight C5 but no I can
but you don't have to play Rook C1 you
could just keep him oh yeah because now
you're not threatening to move your
knight so maybe now I can play here so
of course so the thing is to keep the
threat of King G4 so if somehow this
Knight moves away then King G4 King H5
try to if I get this Pawn I think this
game will be very easy to draw problem
is this Pawn is very far away
so what is the game in the game he
played King H3 which I understand he
wants to go here so it takes takes but I
think Knight F6 here
uh so this I think is going to be a
problem so as long as I don't let you
play King G4 so if you go Rook B6 I will
go Rook f8 so temporarily this looks
very passive but my king can
go to G6 and then I can frame my Rook
yeah I think if the cane were teleported
to G6 black would be would be winning
but
I think why why would be in trouble
yeah I think this position is actually
quite problematic
so the position is so this is actually
the left position so Rook f8 is going to
be played Black has no other move black
is not going to give up this Pawn or
allow the king to come in
so Rook Cafe it can be expected and
we're nearing move 40. so a black will
get additional time on the clock and
very likely we'll
um
win this game I think actually I'm not
going to say that but uh okay I think
the chances of wind have improved
significantly
do you want to take a look at some of
the other matchups yeah let's go back
a
H let's see what happened to our Savion
game there
okay so when we left off this game we're
in this position so Rook F1 was played
so not a lot of moves actually or a lot
of moves now we're here so gets one Rook
one two C2
A5 which makes a lot of sense to me to
just keep pushing this one with D5
and now H4
oh I like this move breaking this pawns
and
maybe in the future we can take this
Rook B2
we can use the help of table
she takes H4
okay but I think something went wrong
for black because I don't like this
exchanges I really like this H4 move by
white
because
um like I think allowing giving black
this punch is really nice yeah and it
makes the F Pawn passed if we can
capture the E6 Pawn which uh we which
happens sort of by force
because I don't think you want to play
Rook E5 here
five actually maybe maybe you do so
takes and then take so maybe we can
something like this
but then this will be some kind of a
like a two versus one
like if I go here here and okay two
versus ones are always like true but I
do have a pass Pawn but I think here
this should be a drop I mean okay a
strong Grand Masters would be able to
hold this quite comfortably
so H4 okay then ml doesn't like the H4
so maybe black should have taken
actually so rookie one instead so now
the problem is you cannot go here
because I will take
so instead he took
so what is the difference so if I take
here you go here okay I have the option
of rookie five and this pawns are
hanging but if I commit Rook beef 2
immediately as it happened in the game
rookie one I cannot go rookie 5.
so J takes H4 Rook E6
um and okay six
really
this this is a bit surprising to me
because
does he think
so this will happen so does he think
that he can hang on to this Pawn because
I don't think he can win both of these
pawns I'll give up H4 I'll hang on so
again if I can do some kind of a
two versus one and I actually learned
recently
how you so the way apparently you hold
this two versus one someone told me
recently is you put a king on H6 and The
Rook on the G file
okay oh wait what is is that necessary
to do uh I thought you could hold it
just by something like this
um so here you actually have to be
careful because you might find yourself
in like a directly lost end game
so for example if you do nothing
like you wait I will go here
yeah and then I just yeah this looks uh
So eventually
so now I'm threatening C7 and check so
you have to go to G7
but now because I have an F Pawn this is
a win because I push it all the way to
F6
yeah it's funny if um black didn't have
like if black could trade both his age
pawns for the f-pawn that would be a
draw yeah this would have been really
good trade but the presence of this
stuff um but this Rook A6 still
surprises me a bit because it feels like
he can Okay so this King also looks a
bit funny to me here maybe he can go
after the age pounds maybe he can go
after like check this King and then
almost feels like a meeting net but okay
obviously we cannot check me the king in
the middle of the board but what does
where does this King go can I Target
this Pawns
like if you go here like a check and
instead of going to E5 maybe we go to E4
with the King but then still check okay
D3
I hate playing passively in these sorts
of end games even when even when I maybe
should but if I trade now let's say yeah
it definitely becomes tougher but now
you go I don't know can I win you
probably the king is not caught up in a
really funny way yeah because usually
the king gets cut off on like seven ring
and that's fine cut off on this right is
this Rook A6 it looks so communal to me
just feels like white should have so
many other options like check this King
around see where this because like I
think when you start like playing this
movie also kind of giving your opponent
the chance to maybe go the wrong way
with the King like if the King goes here
this looks like almost amazing that
somehow
like something like this am I not
threatening me too you are okay yeah
it's just it feels feels bad feels wrong
okay but okay I guess after that black
would play like Rook A4 or something
just just stop F4 but
oh he didn't
so king of five sorry so the game is he
took immediately
yeah Rook k6 oh so this is the final
position
um so what are the options for Block I
think black has to play Rook C2 or is he
thinking Rook C6 is this maybe a win
like the way that we showed and just
start pushing this Pawn
or so I see the eval bar uh probably
would indicate that it's not winning but
I couldn't tell you how
okay like the king is
but how if you go here maybe you can
play H3 at some point I
um just I just want to see so here here
so this this has to be lost because
I just win both pawns because if you go
here I will play here upon F3 and I get
two connected Pawn so you want to play
H3 maybe right away instead of passing
like a while like
yeah sure sure so here if I take teenage
four so if King G2 then Rook C3 Maybe
uh
uh survive the this let me see why not
though
so if I push
so I wanted to take
I push Rook C3 but you can get stuck oh
yeah
but wait they've all dropped why is this
strong
if I can still make myself that would
also be good I don't know how to do it
just like that okay good good
okay but to find this over the floor
that you still made yourself this is
like okay let's see that's the thing
that's about like this little hints just
makes such a big difference someone
tells me in this position you have a
draw
yeah it's just like to stuff still made
yourself with wild
if I do this oh I'm getting made it I
have to be careful okay so here here you
also have a pass Pawn so
so what is the live position so live
position he checks which apparently is a
huge mistake yeah but I can see why
because you're just helping my king
I wonder
um if Sam saw this idea like probably
probably not right like like if you went
for this you probably thought I'm just
straight wedding and yeah he probably
thought I have a c Pawn like I I know
this position with Rook C8 fancy seven
and I have an F Pawn so all those
positions with like that passive defense
oh
um like with the King on G7 H7 is a draw
is a win so he maybe hit that he's just
straightforward winning I guess we can
ask him
well let's see if he's going to win this
okay Rook F1 we have to go F3
but
how do we
what do we do here
so the idea is now I don't have King H2
you're gonna meet me but I do have I
actually lost an end game like that once
uh as like I I recently made 2200 I
played a rapid game against another 2200
and in two there was no C Pawn I think I
had this exact structure and I played
knh3 to try to win and he played Rook H1
Main and I was not happy
painful memories
shout out to Nick Carlo
okay so we'll get fun we're done F3 well
this is Samsung right F3
let me promote this so after it wasn't
played the one that's highlighted so but
I expect F3 to be played and then what
is going to be Black's defense
first
um so the King has to go back
so this cannot be so black cannot just
lose h12 and H4 two connected past pawns
will just be a win so okay so he's just
cutting the king off and now he will go
F3
so if Rook C1
so now the king is stuck going back and
forth
also maybe oh Rook C2 is not possible
because now I can go King H3 and now
your Rook cannot move because you have
to be at all times attacking G2
otherwise I'll take you H4 so now your
Rook is stuck so you have to go King
here but
uh so if I go here
I mean this should also win right just
the way that you described earlier push
the pawn to C7 and then
now the problem is even if you
if you I guess I cannot force you to
yeah I mean I can't even do this right
because something like this I just
if you take with the Rook I can go to an
end game this is the easiest way for me
to win and then I just collect everyone
yeah there are very few keen and pawn
endings down two pawns that are holding
okay so in the game he went King F4
okay
so the idea is if I take you take
advocate for
king of Pawn and games are so tricky
okay so there's several moves so Rook
Chief King G4 is a move take is a move
this must be a win
this has to be a win
yeah I think this is a win I don't want
to say it incorrecting but yeah this has
to be when I think
is Rick H3 Rook F3 also winning or no
like after King E3 can I go Rook H3 and
then Rook F3 because I'm close to the
key squares also like if I go here yeah
like Rook F3 I'm probably forced to go
back yeah I can't play Rick F3 anymore
so sorry
[Music]
not just be
I just want to transpose to lucinas
somehow
[Music]
but if I go let's say I don't know where
I'll go here so I defending my Pawn so I
check so Rook F4 is not a move you have
to go to G5 and now here
and the question is
wait
no I'm not taking them
but I can check right so you cannot go
to the H file I check you go this way
and now I push
this should also be a win somehow yeah
that's good
a yield tickets for next
yeah
um okay so can get four is demo but F3 I
think it's still a possibility
so oh F3 maybe h
um because now I cannot take its mate
yeah that would be unfortunate so I
don't want to do this
maybe you go G3 okay I go G3 you cannot
take because check and the Kings outside
of the square of the sea Pawn
and if you go here then I will check you
go here and maybe
a four four I was also thinking for H4
but your king is caught up so this might
actually be winning yeah this has to be
winning your king because I can also
come out of your King by one more Square
and for you to draw this no you cannot
try this if I need to draw this enough
yeah okay I think F5 I think in order
for you to draw this The Rook also has
flick has to be on like f8 and your cane
has to be
uh cut by only one file oh so this is
the game H3
is there any other movies Roxy forum
move yeah this is also
oh you went okay four did I say Rook C4
I mean okay four
and he's just gonna pick up the pawn
right King here I just yeah it's
actually way simpler YB up one Pawn when
you can be up to
four
king drop your Rook
no this just looks like and a reaching
will 40. so I think some will just you
know I think he can also repeat the
position right
original 40 and then think about what he
wants to do so I think
um this will be very comfortable win for
Sam at this point
yeah that was a very interesting end
game
do you want to take a look at the
Christopher U of Imani Mishra game so we
thought that was pretty exciting oh my
God a normal uh imbalance classic
yeah this is this is the kind of chest
you can see at the spring chest classic
casually down a rook in a bishop for a
bunch of Pawns but look at those pawns
okay so I have
before we go here I have to
have to White Queen
mine too
so you too
oh man
so it's zeros of course of course of
course in this position okay so I'm
trying to Queen so I'm trying to take so
you cannot do anything funny I'll just
Queen
so yeah I don't think you can take
because
oh you have a resource check uh where
does the king go actually
here and queen
yeah but now we have to play this end
game
and then this is like the games oh T4 is
hanging but okay it's still like the
game starts all over again I I feel like
this is like you're playing like three
different games in one because you had
that crazy position and now all of a
sudden you're playing something you know
it's a very technical endgame which
isn't as interesting as it was a moment
ago how did we get to that position
though because there must have been some
crazy tactics
okay so we started with a Sicilian
so we play a naidorf Bishop G5
uh entering the sharper variations so
Knight bd7 T4 this is all Theory
yeah Queen H3 was and um
Christopher does like some very precise
preparation I remember during his
championship he what did you prepare you
print the Scandinavian against linear he
plays some kind of an obscure line and
he did something else against the Rey I
think he prepared some
um I think it was in the Berlin rookie
one Berlin where he like sacrificed the
pawn
but for Ray to win he had to be like
very precise I think he's very good at
like separation was that the line where
you um uh where white takes on E5 and
then plays D4 and just hands their Rook
on E5 but it's like a draw somehow Maybe
I vaguely remember
yeah that that line is
unusual yeah so Christopher is very good
that it's kind of preparation so he
takes B4 oh
that's a gutsy move considering there is
a bishop and
um Queen Odyssey file so Knight 27 G5
E5 oh wow okay so the idea is this must
be losing right tricks takes Bishop D5
is tough to deal with
it's mates
so instead black said I will just give
you a piece
um yeah this kind of sacrifices are
quite common in Sicilians and the
dragons is also possible sometimes black
gives up this bishop on G4 when they
sacrifice for some pawns and of course
with special with this diagonal this is
a very powerful Bishop so right now we
have one two three four one two three
four so three pounds so Bishop D7 and of
course we give this back Knight P3 I
think he thought this bishop is too
strong
can we Castle
one of these two squares
not here Bishop C6 I like Knight A5
somehow to establish 56 right but
something
so what are we doing against B6 I guess
I think Queen
Queen F3 works I don't know
oh yeah I'm not convinced oh yeah
because Queen A8 Queen B8 Queen
um
A6 where's the mate
I think
that has to be made right yeah
Queen takes Queen B6 Knight B5 is not a
check 95 is not a check Rook D7 doesn't
work process of elimination what else do
we have
Queen where
and mate is this mate no uh no it is
yeah
amazing
okay check until it's made okay but Rook
date was played and it goes to C5 Bishop
C8
uh what is the material
just two pieces for rook and a lot of
Pawns
so Knight goes to E4
and
V6 C3 oh my God
so now there's a lot of fonts on the
board yeah I mean it's very difficult to
like try to understand every move in
this position or try to analyze it it's
a rook C1 but why did he hungry four
with a check every move feels like a
puzzle
but okay like here try to maybe he
thought this is too
dangerous for the queen to kind of leave
the king
so Bishop D7 now Knight C5 F5 so they
are eval bar really likes white here
Queen H7 looks very strong
this looks very logical
okay seven I think it's these types of
positions that um the computers like oh
yeah White's doing great and then you
play them they're just like nice I'm
losing with both sides okay so D3 King
B3 oh my God there's so many pawns one
two three four five six yeah white also
has passed phones
mine has two connected postpones as
there was a result between Benjamin
Ghidorah and or sorry yester quesada
president Benjamin gladora I'm not sure
what it was I think I see the keys in
the center so I believe it was a draw I
can't check here quickly yeah this uh
this was a draw
but let's finish our
yeah I mean this this is just such a
treat to look at
25 or four of them what a game what a
battle three four
so E3 and King F6 so this we saw this
position it was played and immediately
Queen d8 but I don't think there is is
there much difference so if I go here
now you see ah okay now I can stay up a
piece
so if you take
take and I take and then we'll start
over and now again I have like uh 17
pounds for the pawn but uh for the piece
but this one actually looks quite
dangerous
Maybe
oh now you're also threatening to
worship yeah this is a very scary for
both sides yeah
I think this might be like the game of
the yeah even even if they draw like
this is such a good such a good game by
both players I still also Play exciting
chess when I was young
you can calculate this much
okay so this was very exciting we can
see this game
um this game between and we do see the
players on the board and the playing
card reader
so we will see
um we'll see what happens in that game
so we have this position so King G6 was
played so now it's way to move so I
expect
maybe there's some Perpetual here
actually
I think I don't know
or the king can maybe try to hide
maybe you yeah
can you try to go up the Border like
like kinji or no no
but uh after you play like Queen d8
check
um like when I play King F6 maybe I can
think F5
and then if I go
here you have I still have to go back
but maybe I can try Queen E4
yeah at some point I'm gonna have to do
this right but uh now I get to no but
now this is not good for you didn't get
my pawn and without this Pawn I actually
have a blockade here so you have three
membership D3 is a huge threat so became
a bit of a problem ambition with black
might not be a good thing
[Music]
yes the 96 there should be three
this is someone
um
interesting Cecilia and I always find
this night to be annoying here I had a
very similar structure it gets here in a
crush except my position was better and
my I had to play this g3h4h5 and I
didn't
it was a must win game for me too
a night of Fate but this position looks
cool to me it looks Pleasant for whites
the two Bishops
the prospect of the Bishops is very
strong in general and just
C5
I understand C5 trying to develop this
bishop on killing this bishop but
um maybe immediately some F5 and Bishop
F4 ideas are in the air
takes takes rookie eight
and the Evolve bar just jumped up I
should buy four was played Queen F7
Oh I thought Rook D6
and Bishop D6 makes a lot of sense too
though right you eliminate the Knight
and then take E6
C8 Queen G4
wait I wonder oh okay so
I was thinking maybe you wanted to
take but
yeah but it's it's not as good
yeah here I wanted Rook D6 but I guess
you take with the queen to stop 56 maybe
yeah okay
and it still looks unpleasant there's
this unpleasant pin on the king
but our evolver just went up like crazy
I try not to look I mean I have the
engines like one line I try not to look
at it that's what sometimes my eye
catches it yeah I can only see the no
I'm in my like I said
because very strong because opening the
[Music]
position something like this
too and then Rook F1 this looks pretty
devastating
instead Queen G4 is played King h8
trades wins upon but I wonder why not
win Upon This Way
issues also
this would be my so maybe he thought
there's something more concrete
maybe he missed Queen E7
maybe he thought it takes which is of
course not rookie summon is coming yeah
maybe he missed 207 immediately
King F2
so it takes takes okay still up a pawn
but I think the worst is behind
black looking cooking enough Tracy for
oh that's a nice move and now the queen
comes in I was actually gonna say maybe
white wants to play C4 himself at some
point like maybe here you can try C4 I
don't know if I care yeah I think here
then the queen comes from here maybe 25
yeah it's like what happened in the game
like C4 is such a nice move because now
all of a sudden things shift right the
queen is coming and the queen this White
Queen finds herself to be on the wrong
spot of the board it's like the switch
in the position and all of a sudden your
piece is misplaced
yeah your king could even end up not so
safe
yeah but here black has a lot of counter
playing
yeah nice resource by black here
oh okay this is the same pattern now it
goes on the darks first again not from
this side yeah this is a really nice
defense my black takes a lot of Trades
and
I'm expecting to see some kind of a
Perpetual oh no they just agreed
yeah move forward they agreed to draw
yes but there's a purpose so even though
this game was a draw
um I'm sure uh well quesada Perez
definitely uh
should be a little disappointed in this
one he was doing really well earlier and
black needed to find some really nice
moves to make a draw yeah black I think
put up a really great defense here
so in this game uh yeah this game Sam's
position
has made a lot of progress yeah really
nice move G4 here instead of taking and
playing with this separated pants he
keeps the pawns connected his ideas to
play Rook H5 take this Pawn
so he plays King G2 Rook suit
of course again
this problem should be winning again but
why play with the separated pawns he
just checks and actually he will be
he might be up three points right yeah
I I've just learned that savian actually
won this game so
um that makes sense it makes sense yeah
he's about to be up three pawns and
oh and we have another result in group a
in Victor michalevski's game and
um how did this game end
let's see white one I believe in this
game
uh no wait it's Houston oh it's Black's
turn Okay so that came and a draw
so let's see what happened there g3b5
this is a quite a combative move
because
um the idea is to play in this king's
Indian attack positions the pawn and B5
is actually useful
for a lot of action in the center D5
some kind of a yeah I've played this
system with black and you have to be
careful not to get your Bishop on B7
shut out like this
so it results just keep uh coming in I
believe Benjamin Bach and illianishnik
have drawn their game
and that's a nice recovery for Benjamin
box so we actually got a benoni
fianchetta benoni so it's a double
double fan shadow
I have a lot of experience with a poor
light squared Bishop
so 91 oh really nice maneuver but now
black is stopping it by attacking E4
King G1
H4 wait
this part is hanging at some point right
spot was hanging wait can I take
I mean I understand it's
scary
um
a lot of things are hanging maybe Knight
Bishop G7 Knight G5 now okay I
understand why taking this Pawn is very
scary
so Knight G5
so now white is up upon
okay but black has some kind of a
blockade but isn't F4 coming at some
point yeah the bishop on B7 doesn't seem
too good right now
oh why does not have a problem it just
it just feels that way yeah maybe E5 is
I would think like a 45 maybe five is a
bit too per middle usually this exchange
is good for white but yeah another
Bishop on B7 actually like kind of makes
sense because the five is hanging yeah
this was I think if five was
um played too quickly like preparing F4
and then trying to play five would make
more sense perhaps
because okay if I can play five and have
disconnected fast one so I'd be quite
happy but if I Rook C8 yeah Rook said
the problem is the queen does not have a
good Square to go to and D5 Falls
immediately so maybe he missed that to
roxy8 and the queen doesn't have a good
Square to go to and the game ends in a
drone
so this other game that we're looking at
looks like
black brother came to G6 yeah black made
a lot of progress we left off somewhere
around here so the king came to G6
but some quite a bit of work to do
because the pawn structure is quite
solid so
so white just needs to exchange if what
does white needs to experience this
cheap one somehow
okay black still has to find a way to
break through because if I'm doing
nothing
what is going to be Black's idea
so let's say you put a knight on F4
right and then
I do nothing
so you
maybe bring the king in and try to
exchange the Rooks
oh maybe it's rugby two move here
yeah that's that's clever
yeah this end game should be winning
it's so tricky with knights because if
you go F4 I will just ignore because
like this exchange okay especially not I
don't know if I want to take no this
should be easy because my knight should
be able to come and take all these Pawns
yeah unlike with Bishops you don't have
to be super concerned with the wrong
color which
um
you might be otherwise
yeah so maybe Knight F4 is already a
thread of Rook B2
so let's say King goes up
but now I can check
do I want to check into four
I I thought again thought this is
amazing that but it's not
maybe we can play rookies rookie three
check after Kane E5 and just like say
that White's cane isn't super useful on
that side of the board like Rook D3 King
E5 Rook E3 okay maybe oh yeah
even so I don't think
I don't think this is such an easy win
yeah now it actually looks like they can
belongs hunting for
maybe sure
encourage this King okay and this other
game that we were looking at that Ox
shot our tournament leader going into
this round
we left off somewhere around here so
this was paid this is actually exactly
where I left off so he went P3 and
immediately B5
and with the idea of going from A4 and
breaking the spawn structure so whenever
you have a pawn chain you want to go
after the root of the pawn so takes
takes Knight H4
equals to D7
um
and queen F7 yeah I think yeah the worst
is probably over for rockshot definitely
a lot of moves
and there was
a point
okay it's nice tempo
G6
look C5 that's a nice move wait why did
okay after uh so when he played rookie
eight uh we're not losing a piece
because after 97 we can just move
and uh if we take on D5 with the queen
we don't have to recapture on D5 we take
on E7
nice maybe you can take one I don't know
which I don't know but maybe we take
this while also this hangs at the end
yeah so that was a good catch so Queen
F3 G6 Rook C5
uh so taking this way looks scary
because you're getting made it all of a
sudden yeah and then if you played Queen
G3 my favorite tactic or glitch one
we had something similar right in Kirk's
game yeah
so Queen D5 instead was played
King G6 Rook B8
Rook A3 F4
they look so passive on A3 yeah this is
like the worst place for The Rook to be
because ideally you want the Rook behind
on the side you want it to be on C3 on
D3 but like on the corner on the side
it's just not doing anything and this
king is so active it's coming to take
all the pawns so Rook H5 this is a good
practical chance
so what are we going to have are we
going to have
two versus one or if I take okay if I go
for this it's two versus one but I don't
think I want to allow this I think I can
just defend right
okay yeah we don't even have to play two
versus one but also the two versus one
isn't super dangerous right like with
the H Pawn like I think if we take and
go King E5
or E4 sure yeah oh E5 that's what you
said
um yeah this King also maybe we can cut
this king off yeah
I don't think black's in a whole lot of
danger in this one yeah
on but there's no reason to allow this
yeah for sure
this game ended there's a few games we
haven't quite looked at there's so many
games Okay so this game that I see on
the board this looks this looks like a
draw
I think I think this game actually has
already concluded in a draw
I believe because we are plasma 40 I
this position is just a draw there's no
way to break through here opposite color
Bishops there's no soups amongst or
anything
like that and another game
that's actually a very interesting end
game
so what is the position so Rook two
pounds versus two minor pieces
so our players are clive.in and Jason
Liang Jason Liang he did draw that game
yesterday it was the Italian were
looking at so white is pricing here
but
um
my black has a nice blockade so what is
the point here
so we cannot so if we push the pawn
then something like this might be
interesting but of course the Knight
will take and that's this will hang so
maybe white can start
what blocks I do is to play King C5 on
here So eventually we have to defend
this Pawn
right
yeah how do you ever make progress in
the Sim game
maybe on the king side we try to so the
question is can this king move
I was trying to figure out oh King c6s I
was trying to be a bit clever here I
thought if you take with the bishop I
take the solder Pawns of course we
cannot take with the Knight but of
course you take this way but apparently
King C5 is a big mistake
yeah and I saw the move which yeah I
also saw G5 but uh even and then if I go
back
so how do we make progress here that's
very good question yeah I still don't
fully understand so we can go all the
way maybe we can shoot someone and
maybe the thing is we go yeah we play
like H4 so H2 isn't hanging ever and
then like
or sure yeah uh and then bring Arcane to
like
actually I don't know where yeah we
can't go all the way to G4 we can go
each
I'm going H5 but long time okay so blood
can probably just go back and forth and
just um hold this position yeah I'm not
I don't see what's the great idea so if
we just make some moves
and then this King comes here so let's
say King H3 if I'm waiting King here I'm
waiting H5 I'm waiting
no I don't I don't really see
way to break through here
so this um this might just be a blockade
and I don't see how to make progress
here
so let's keep going through the game so
this game ended this game we expect
um
to also end in a draw
and this one I think black still has a
lot of work to do to win
so we can go back to group a we had the
game between Benjamin Bach and
elianiznik that ended
in a draw and we will have
um
we have some other results as well
and oh it looks like Darius Schwartz is
winning his game against not their back
this is actually a game we have not
taken a look at and
Samuel Savion we saw that he won his
game we have
just one more game going in this section
Christopher you game that we're still
looking at that was a very fascinating
and we do have a guest in the studio
with us Victor michalevski I haven't
seen you in so long I know we used to
play in the US a lot we actually have
played so it's nice to see you again so
you had a
um
draw with the white pieces so what do
you think were the key moments in this
game in fact I won on time but it was
time yeah
I did not realize that
um okay so let's take a look at the game
so you played this position so you
decided not to play with d34 and then
at some point you got some kind of a
double fan shadowed benoni yeah well I
think this position should be better for
white
because of your nice Pawn structure and
yeah and the bishop on B7 is bad so
yeah but then I probably misplit it
so all of this still looks very nice for
you
yeah yeah
but but then I wasn't so sure how to
play this position
yeah it looks logical but
sorry for
so what do you think about this before
move
probably before was an accurate but uh
two moves later I just made a bad move I
think after A5 was correct Queen did and
now I think 91 was a mistake I
completely forgot that I'm not in time
to play Knight d2c4 like the game
probably I had to play like Knight B1 my
initial idea was even to sacrifice the
pawn with Knight A4
and then the other night is coming to C4
and so that's very nice oh yeah that's a
nice combination yeah or or even Bishop
G7 Knight B2 Knight C4 like this
oh let's take this way right all night
b2c4
Kansas coming and so that's really nice
but then uh when when we got this
position I thought why should they give
this spawn we can just play 91 and play
same position with equal pawns but then
after he played Knight F6 I realized I
cannot play Knight D2 just uh he takes
the D5 Pawn oh yes I guess that's what I
forgot about it was either way oh that's
unfortunate and they cannot play Knight
E3 as well because A4 Pawn is hanging
oh so you forgot that immediately then I
thought no I I saw Knight F6 I thought I
can play Knight G2 and forgot about the
D5 Pawn
yeah I thought I need to protect the
Rook so I can play Knight d2c4 maybe an
ID tonight E3
yeah H5 was interesting in fact so he's
kind of preventing id2 because then he
can go H4 I could probably still play it
and the allow H takes G3 but
probably still good for me but
reunited yeah this is hanging already
yeah but I try to get the same position
with without even allowing H4
so I played King G1 yeah with the idea
of plane H4 so we're actually wondering
is it possible yeah I think 94 was very
sharp I wasn't sure because I think I
should play Bishop G2 that was my idea
obviously too yeah because if I play
Knight G5 instead I think he can
sacrifice the queen Knight takes
seven Knight F3 checking G2 and The Rook
takes E7 and they cannot take the Knight
because of Bishop takes D5 and that gets
Checkmate oh wow this is beautiful yeah
I can get four Bishop H6 wow this is
really nice
and so and now 91 is a huge threat maybe
you need to go I could go to H1 but then
he just takes rookie seven and oh this
D5 is hanging
three yeah
yeah but I wasn't so happy about this
position frankly yeah like he has a rook
Rook Knight and the pawn for the queen
and a nice position I think so that's
why I was going to play Bishop G2
instead instead of Knight G5 with the
idea of Knight G5 and here I wasn't so
sure he has some moves like I don't know
Bishop takes B2 maybe or
uh I think I should take with the night
oh this is defended okay yeah because I
I need an item E4 to be attacked and now
if Queen F6 I can play Rook a31 that was
my idea and tonight is still pinned
oh yeah so but yeah but here yeah and
just Knight G5 I think wow this is so
sharp yeah I wasn't sure yeah but here
it looks like you're winning a piece
right probably here I'm winning a piece
but yeah I wasn't so sure I thought he
will play Knight E4
so he won 9g4 instead he took the Knight
G5
yeah
I think this position should be good for
weight yeah so here you're already
getting everything you wanted ready
because yeah Knight to C4 yeah
still I was short on time and wasn't so
sure I had to convert
yeah I mean maybe rookie one was too
slow I don't know
because he started to
so in this position why did you decide
to go for E5 just because it was certain
times I thought maybe a form yeah maybe
it works yeah but then he may have check
maybe rookie seven I wasn't so sure or
just rookie seven right away
son can we kick the coin away yeah
something like this yeah but then I'm
not sure how I'm making progress here
because I don't know if I can play A5
maybe it will just be a conversion
because it looks like after E5 no yeah
it's just equalizer right yeah
yeah now it's first
Queen before Bishop D5 rookie five
yeah we thought it was just a drive
because it was more 40 but yeah that's
very unfortunate but here okay you're up
a pond but no no you can play Rook B7
instead of taking on G2 in fact
no like later after rookie five Rook B7
hi okay yeah and then yeah just gets it
back immediately
okay well I mean yeah and when it's a
win yeah I know it's not the way you
would want to win but yeah yeah that's
very unfortunate and yesterday you had a
very interesting game you played that
King's Indian with a pan soccer player
it was a very instructive game where um
with your a pawn but eventually I saw
that and the dinner yeah I could have
even lost this
well good luck thank you for joining us
and good luck in the rest of your games
and we hope to see you back here again
and uh let's continue looking through
our games so the last game we looked at
was this game and we're talking about
in this position black instead
so Bishop C7 all this moves were played
and white went uh H4 and black went F6
not allowing this immediate G5 move
and let's see what other games we have
left so this game ended and aksha
Chandra is now playing down the Ponto
versus one week this is a terrible drum
position we expect this game to end in a
draw and in group b we still have this
position white hasn't made a move yet so
let's go back to group a where we have
this fascinating game between
Christopher you and arimani Mishra where
um so
eventually
in this position
so it took this pawn and now again we
have a pawn race so we already had
one of the ponds at Quint and apparently
this game is completely equal Queen D1
check is coming the spawn is going to be
queening but this is a very scary
position to play and
um yeah I don't I don't know why okay
it's easy for the computer to say zero
but I think probably this is scary and
we do have a guest in the studio some
saving congrats on your win thank you so
first uh tell me what you think about
this position uh I mean this game was
insane for me yeah we saw this game yeah
so it did seem winning for weight but at
some point the computer was saying so we
started from here we're White Queen and
then all of this happened I actually
didn't see what happened here so all of
this happened you're probably the Ponder
enough
so all of wait so this is apparently is
very good
it's kind of a sturdy-like position
why is it so good it's so hard oh he
could have picked up the g75 for free
ah because you cannot go here this just
loses a queen
but is it so important to take this G7
Pawn probably for Queen F6 reasons later
also he missed it so he checked can get
five oh he didn't miss it no he took it
oh he shouldn't have taken it
some reason
yeah so before
so
so I think moving this bishop was good
because
so it's not uh I guess the point is if
they're P5
G3 we can probably play Queen
E5
and then claim that this person cannot
move just pick up the F3 Pawn oh okay
so I don't have a move but again if I go
here you take I can just go 24 just take
the pawn oh yes okay you just want to
take the after Pawn okay
oh so instead he took the pawn which is
not good
and then push the pawn queen do one is a
nice move oh so they can just Heights
here
and now we have this position so do you
think it's going to be a draw it's
probably the bishop will give up itself
the B6 Queen T1 seems forced
okay if we block they just taken G yeah
it should be a drop and if I block
Ed that might be scary for White Queen
D5 and then that's fun
so for example if I this is sorry worst
case I can always go takes G3 I think
oh something like this yeah
does this and then
this is a perpetual
oh but here I don't even have a threat
right because this is working okay wow
crazy game
yeah this was a really wild game from
the beginning it was at some point it
was Rook against like four pawns and
yeah yeah it was a pretty insane
position all right let's take a look at
your game so you had a really nice win
um so let's take a look so you played
so you're white you're playing the
Berlin end game yeah I think he mixed up
a plan too he played Bishop B7 with the
idea of net H4 and then he played H5 on
the next move
usually people don't mix those two right
yeah we're also talking about H5 and
Julian was saying that usually
want to play should be six so your king
goes the other way okay so he went
Bishop wait four H5
rookie one
yeah basically uh yeah takes takes 92 is
nice and I want to play Knight D4 here
uh followed by E6 and he played A6
really quickly to stop Knight D4 yeah
but he missed that I can go E6 yeah this
is very thematic for the structures and
he has to take with the bishop we talked
about this so now C7 is hanging yeah so
the interesting part was this uh Rook
end game that we reached
so in this position
like what did you think of your chances
I thought maybe instead of Rook takes B7
I should have taken control over of the
D5 with Rook D1
ah also playing and then just bring the
king to E3
so I think there's really good technical
chances here King goes to E3 and Black's
Pat Rook is so passive so he has the
difference he can still play B5 because
I can't do K7 yet then I bring my king
over
was kind of risky by me
but it's still very difficult to defend
for black he started off doing the right
move so Rook D2 is fine Rook D it's good
Rook D6 is good rookie two is good yeah
this was really nice I think he has to
go A5
it's the safest move uh we're thinking
of just waiting that's what he played oh
that is what yeah if not to allow you A5
because now it becomes really difficult
for him and in this position what do you
think about C5 I was considering Rook 66
Rook 66
P4 I think Rook D3 the only one yeah
it's B5
takes takes I'm not sure um I think I
have good chances here
yeah yeah we're looking at this and
there was some kind of a just by force
who reached King and fun end game there
was a drop but of course yeah I think
yeah yeah and I think a lot of these
decisions also like if I pick up the C5
pawn and then play H4 GH Rook takes H5
that two versus one ending is pretty
unpleasant for black yeah
so it's so you think he shouldn't have a
lot so he should have played a five here
a rookie two is fine
here I think A5 is a corrective B4
uh the idea is now he goes Rook C2
so I was planning to play B3 instead of
B4
and place C4 and just like stay solid
attacked upon an A5 or k6 still
definitely difficult for black but in
the game
after A5
Rook D5 Rook C6 Rook A5 I found this
really nice of H4 yeah I thought I
thought it was really nice uh apparently
black can hold but that's just take
take a rookie one
I was thinking rookie five years
interesting yeah we're analyzing those
King 65 Rook takes A6
so this is also very likely to go to
some tours as well yeah exactly through
K5 this is what I was talking about just
now so here I take on H5 xc2
and either I can take on H4 and play
this a really unpleasant end game where
I can keep the pawn Rook C5
which one do you think gives you better
winning chances
um
honestly I was considering playing Rook
C5 during the game because I can always
take this Pawn Yeah you can always
transform through this position yeah
there's some really
um the recent games were white one
descent game pretty easily I have lost
the sun game before yeah it's definitely
difficult
so H4 yeah he won Rook V2 this is
definitely and rookie one it's a really
nice move
and here we're wondering because you
took on A6 immediately and we're
wondering did you calculate it until 11
because it looks like Rook F6 is kind of
unpleasant shank to give if King G5
uh
yeah I thought Rook 686 was a pretty
easy win okay interested how the
computer defends
uh I think how does the computer defend
I think it's just uh yeah but I thought
this is a win for you because you have
the F Pawn I thought this was the win
too so King G5 Rook C5 check
King G6 let's say it goes C4 yeah
you can gauge six Rook C8
King G5 C5 oh yeah it was there's this
uh amazing idea that
oh well okay okay no no one is finding
this over the world that's insane
oh it's so concrete because because my
part has to be on C5 yeah yeah it has to
be the same level okay finding this over
the board is just impossible yeah I
thought it was completely winning after
6. yeah
this position because Ruby one there's
no fight no oh not this yeah yeah
without like this position you thought
it's a win because uh in that uh if you
push the pawn all the way like we're
looking at here
I guess we were saying like this
position yeah
it's really cool yeah because like the
computer also just drops we're trying to
figure out why and then it's just this
crazy idea
but instead rugby one was if I play a C6
instead of allowing stalemate
so here here oops not that so here's his
six now but that then yeah
but I think this one
so I can H2 F4
I guess I'm way too slow
oh it's also still me again F5
King H1 F6 all right just H2 F7
but do I have to
can I do this
I have King E2
I cannot move this check can I no I
cannot oh yeah
King's two four Yeah well yeah this was
a fascinating end game well is this
thing game actually drawn if based on
this
I do
oh I'd like this whole end yeah
let me find this like the sun game yeah
so Rook C2 Rook C6 King G5 if I sit with
Rook C4 I'm just King G6
yeah there's not really because F3 I
assume they go H3
uh maybe I would try something like this
because I I understand it's a draw but
it's very difficult to do I mean I'm
gonna attack the H Pawn
I mean maybe if you reach this kind of
position right if you're already here
your opponent can find H3 but just to
think he probably also thought that this
is also a h3c6
uh I guess Rook C1
engage to HG King G2 and I think oh and
we can go see E6 uh
one time I thought that maybe I hide
okay yeah
hide here too or this is bad
this doesn't work
out okay so so instead of Rook takes A6
a rook F6 check please
uh
so you have to go H3 now to get me
because F4 is actually a very strong
throat so H2 G3
and then just try it and we want to
engage to above
I mean this is an unnecessary to
calculate because Rook A6 seems so
completely winning yeah I think if yeah
because there's no way you can find this
stuff
I don't know this still made idea you
can't yeah but there's no way you can
find it yeah unless someone tells us not
really an end game you'd ever analyze
with H5 H4 yeah
and then everything that happened was
very yeah this is you just pick up the
ponds and once you pick up the stones
yeah this was very nice because you just
get to keep both parts I didn't feel
like calculating so yeah yeah nice very
nice Victory and yesterday uh you tried
oh yes and who would you play tomorrow
uh easy tomorrow and you'll be playing
with The Blacklist yes well
congratulations on your win very nice
end game and we hope to see you back
here again after many Victors thank you
and let's see
what other games we have let's look at
mishra's game is
um
what is going on here so there's been
some checks here
so the pawn is all the way in B6 let's
say we'll see another set of Queens on
the board
and check so I'm
I think this game is winding down either
there's going to be some Perpetual or
there is going to be that end game that
we saw where
why it was queening or the Queen's
letter word being traded and G Pawn was
queening and was going to be a drum
so I believe in this
so this is the only game we have left
and this game yes we have all the
results so the only game we have in
group a is this Christopher U versus
game and in group b so mikhalevsky
actually flagged we thought it was a
draw
this game is still going so this game
without we couldn't find a way for black
to for white to breakthrough so we will
see if white comes up with an idea
we'll have a try here we have okay this
game is going to be a very easy draw I
think the fact that the king went to E5
indicates that this game is a draw
because black is not thinking if I fear
and character versus Aryan
okay some developments have happened
so let us see what is going on here it's
looking after another four
check
and this is the position okay so it
feels like that after G3
this is
um
some kind of an achievement for
blog but let's see how we can exploit
this
so The Rook on E6 is very well placed
defending the pawn
and now the king can maybe start coming
in
or can we try to win a pawn with rookie
three
so Knight E1 is not a move something
like this
is this how white has to defend this
looks a bit sad so maybe now the king
can start coming in because F4 will run
into Knight G4 with a temple
yeah certainly white is suffering a bit
and black is going to be pressing this
maybe for a long time maybe maybe not
the White House 22 minutes so again
yesterday Kirk was on the worst side of
the position but he had more time which
is I think very important when you're
defending to have more time than your
opponent at least so you know you have
that going for you
and what else do we have so I think we
have those three games left so
Christopher you came you can keep an eye
on
and we see the players in the playing
call it's very been a very intense very
entertaining game
and we had this interview with some
serend I think that was a very
instructive end game it's one of the
things to keep in mind if you ever have
this in a game you know you can draw
this game and I also believe we have the
standings for our groups to see how the
tournament is progressing so far
so Sam sebian has won today and has tied
for the lead because yeah circus out of
Perez uh Drew today they stand on one
and a half points out of two
um there will be a multi-way tie for a
second with one out of two and
um
uh some people struggling at the bottom
with half a half a point and one person
currently on zero but probably not going
to stay that way that's Abi monumentra
yeah and here are the standings for
Group B Victor mithilevski has won his
games today which means he will tie it
tie for the lead with akshat Chandra
with one and a half out of two so there
are no perfects in any of the groups
um and there's again going to be a a
two-way tie for second place with one
out of two uh with Felix and Luca and
several people on half a point out of
one uh tied for third place
well this has been a really fascinating
ground uh really many games that I
enjoyed I really enjoyed this end game
by some Savion it was so instructive
something I didn't know before and he
didn't know before so I think we all
learned something in this game and of
course this game between Christopher you
and abimani Mishra has been a very
fascinating battle and we expect this
game to be winding down and ending in a
drop
the EV every game everyone's fighting
it's super exciting uh definitely uh you
guys should tune back in tomorrow at 4
P.M for our coverage of the third round
of the screen chess classic
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited